Magnus somebody call
him somebody tweeted Magnus and there he
is he
is it looks like he just got out of the
swimming
pool he lost track time guys he lost
track of time he's throwing on a shirt
he's he's trying to button up his shirt
he knows that if he buttons his shirt on
camera it's going to go viral exactly
he's trying to do it off the side but
can
awkward and I
there he is and he is now here 20
seconds only only 30 seconds I you know
it felt longer to me didn't it that was
bizarre beyond belief I've never seen
that happen ever like we've never had
that happen in commentary it can only
happen in online play obviously but gez
guys that is just insane Queen H4 and
queen takes F6 that looks crushing I
mean that just looks instantly crushing
druk G3 played instead and
Magnus has it is resigned